Ultron: I was designed to save the world.
People would look to the sky and see
hope.
I'll take that from them first.
There's only one path to peace.
Their extinction.
Tony Stark: I tried to create
a suit of armor around the world.
but I created something terrible.
Artificial Intelligence.
It's called the Ultron program.
Captain America: I'm sick of watching
people pay for our mistakes.
Isn't why we fight so we can end the
fight and go home?
Well, you amazingly failed.
Nick Fury: Here we all are
with nothing but our wit and our will to save the world.
So stand and fight.
Tony Stark: No way we all get through this.
I've got no plans tomorrow night.
I'm always picking up after you boys.
Ultron: We can tear them apart
from the inside.
Is that the best you can do!?
You had to ask.
Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie.
So this is gonna be my breakdown of this
final Ultron footage. Obviously we get
to see the Vision, lots of cool stuff. I'm
also giving away a subscription to the
Marvel Collector Corps
that's like their Funko Pop! giveaway thing. It's the
only way to get the Hulkbuster Funko.
So I'll announce the winner of that next week. All you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment below.
So let's go. So this is a better shot of Ultron's layer
in Sokovia, that's the fictional country
where this is taking place.
It sounds a lot like this Kurt Busiek run
where he took over this fictional
country called Slorenia.
This shot here from the end of the
trailer, it looks very similar to this shot
from the comic book.
So I think a lot of the story was lifted
from this. We get confirmation
that Ultron is working with Quicksilver
and Scarlet Witch
or he co-ops their services. It'll be
interesting to see what happens to make
them switch sides and help the Avengers.
This shot here is obviously the new Quinjet. Its also
an illusion to Ultron and the Vision, just
two sides of the same coin.
Joss Whedon's teased them as being this Cain and
Abel type story,
you know, good brother, bad brother. So when he
says "There's only one path to peace,
their extinction" he's talking about man
in general, like all of man
not just the Avengers. And here's where the
destruction porn starts.
New shot of the Avengers Tower. In this
movie all the Avengers are living in
this. If you remember at the end of
the first Avengers film
when Tony Stark was looking at the
plans with Pepper Potts they have rooms
for all the Avengers.
This is a shot of Ultron putting himself
together.
It looks like this jumps backwards in time.
Like that first time that
Ultron crashes in on the party and he's
made of an old Iron Man drone that
looks like it got blown up in an
explosion,
this looks like it leads up to that. Joss Whedon said that we would see an evolution to
Ultron. They even showed, this is actually
the picture of
Ultron 1.0. Tony Stark kind of explains
it in this scene too.
He starts out as a peacekeeping program
that he formed during the Chitauri invasion
in the first Avengers film.
And then that's when things go off the rails and he
starts to evolve. When he says he was trying
to wrap the world in a suit of armor what
he was trying to do was create an army
of Iron Man drones to do the job of
the Avengers in cleaning up Hydra.
Cleaning up the world in general too but
but mostly taking care of the biggest threats.
Ever since the end of Winter Soldier the
Avengers have been flying all over the world
cleaning up messes. So they're super
exhausted and Tony Stark is like "Wait.
I got a plan. I could totally build robots to do
this for us." What could go wrong with that plan?
Here's more confirmation on the Bruce Banner
Black Widow relationship.
This is the money shot here with all the
Avengers flying through the air at the same time
down this snowy hill chase. It's funny
because if you saw the Ninja Turtles movie
they did a shot exactly like that
where the Ninja Turtles were in a fight
while they were flying down a hill.
That's Loki's scepter with the Mind Gem
in it. A lot of people are wondering what this is.
It just looks like an advanced S.H.I.E.L.D.
carrier taking people to safety.
It could be Iron Man's mobile armory. In
the comics he has an armory that he
flies around with them that has all
kinds of different armors depending
on what his needs are.
Captain America laying it into Ultron
final boss form with his shield.
It's kind of up in the air as to how Wakanda
figures into this movie because
we don't meet Black Panther until Captain
America: Civil War.
But Ultron in the comics has always
wanted to get his hands on vibranium to make himself
as strong as possible. Ulysses Klaw,
supposed to be in the film
so we could get some teasers for
vibranium, maybe not.
Black Widow picking up Captain America's
shield. There was a lot of teasers earlier
about everyone trying to pick up Thor's
hammer
and Black Widow in the comics has picked
up Thor's hammer. I think there'll be a
lot of playing around with different
Avengers picking up other Avenger's
weapons. I don't think we're gonna see
any other characters wield Thor's hammer though.
That would be awesome, Captain America
picking up Thor's hammer for real.
When Ultron says "We can tear them
apart from the inside" he's talking about
Scarlet Witch taking control of their minds
so we might get some really twisted flashbacks.
She also might be mind controlling the
Hulk here just because this shot comes
right after he said that.
Mind controlling the Hulk to go crazy on
everyone. This shot of Iron Man dragging the Hulk
up the building is actually kind of a
reverse shot of the Hulk
catching Iron Man flying down in the
first Avengers film.
Here's confirmation of that. So here's Scarlet
Witch actually controlling
Black Widow's mind. Quiksilver giving it to Cap.
We don't really know what the extent of
Scarlet Witch's powers are gonna be but it
looks like she has a form of tactile kinesis
so it looks like she's gonna be throwing them
around quite a bit too. And this is a
nice mirror for that Avengers Assemble
moment, you know, when the camera spun around
them in the first Avengers film and they
started taking it to the Chitauri.
Thor challenges Ultron so Ultron sends
his army of replicants after him.
It even looks like Iron Man has
different armor in this than he does
earlier in the trailer, it's kinda
hard to tell. So his armor might change
throughout the film just like it did in
the first Avengers film. Here's a nice
final shot of final boss form Ultron. If
you remember there was promo footage
of him from Comic-Con where he looked
different so that might be his second
form before he turns himself into this.
This is what leads to that promo art
that they released last year too,
the Avengers getting buried in
replicants. And here
we see the Vision. I wonder how many
color swatches it took to get him right.
Joss Whedon said that they spent forever
just trying to get the color of his face
right, that shade of red
which I think is kind of funny. And if we
look here, does this not look like the Soul Gem
from Thanos's gauntlet. Don't want to call it too soon
but I believe that the Soul Gem is what
makes the Vision Vision.
He obviously starts out as A.I. but he has a
soul, he has a silicon soul, that's a big
part of the character
and the Soul Gem would be the logical way
within the context of this movie to explain that.
You guys can let me know if you agree though. Do you
think that this is the Soul Gem? I know
there's a lot of questions as to how he gets
created in the film.
He's gonna save the day. Obviously he's
gonna turn on Ultron but we don't know if they
changed it so that Tony Stark also
created the Vision
or if it's like the comic books and Ultron
created him. Thematically I think it's a little bit better
if they follow the comics but they've already
changed so much so I'm not gonna freak
out if they change even more.
So let me know what you guys think of
this trailer. Let me know you're most excited
about after seeing this.
Personally I'm most jazzed up about the
Vision. I really want to see him in action.
My next bonus Avengers video is probably gonna be
a Scarlet Witch video, just a character video
from my favorite Scarlet Witch stories from
the comics just because I haven't done a
video on her yet. So
be sure to subscribe to get that. Feel
free to leave a request though.
I'm working on a new Arrow video for Death
in the Family, like Batman: Death in the
Family so I'm gonna explain that from the comics
for those that haven't read that story run.
While you guys wait for that to drop you
can click here for my top 5
Ultron stories from the comics and you
can click here to catch up on Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.,
it came back last night.
They're doing Inhumans, it's gonna be
awesome. Thanks so much for watching,
I'll see you guys tonight. Now let's all do the thing.